so some of the largest problems facing
the world's poorest
today our issues of
will health economic development and
political corruption what role if any do
you see the tech industry playing in
addressing these problems well I'm not
sure I think that certainly there are
products that can make a difference I
think generally speaking access to
information that has grown in the last
decade in a way the world is never
before seen has has got to help that
situation because I think as people in
those places get more educated and
informed about what the rest of the
world is like what their options are how
other societies manage I think they will
they will rise up and they will make a
difference in their own lives I don't
think you know the tech world is going
to come in and magically solve any
specific thing but certainly as we've
seen with the Arab Spring last year the
role of technology was you know really
enormous and we always said at palm you
know palm was always about that personal
computing would be mobile computing that
the future of personal computing was
mobile computing and that your device on
you would be your access to the world
and much more so than your desktop
device your desktop device a couple
thousand dollars with an IT person for
every 10 devices with lots of support
last thing you know that just was never
going to fly into the poor parts of the
world in terms of being a reasonable way
for people to get access to the rest of
the world and information in the
internet but these handheld devices
could get cheap enough to do that and we
always said there'll be more accesses to
the internet from a handheld device
particularly the poor parts of the world
then from desktop devices and I believe
that is happening i think the explosion
of software based cell phones with
technology to get on the internet is
democratizing information in a way the
world has never seen before so you know
i think that's probably the biggest
impact you can have as education and
information and then see where people go
with it you know it's just too big of an
issue to take on directly